hey with something on in 2 Samuel Leeds
and on this video I want to be giving
you 10 ways how you can improve your
credit score in the UK to go and buy a
local mall properties the first way to
improve your credit rating is to know
what it is you need to know what it is
otherwise you've got nothing to work on
I recommend a site called credit to
karma there are different sites that do
this but Credit Karma is what I
personally use that's the first thing
second thing is don't freak out if your
credit is not perfect 710 is the maximum
zero is the lowest maybe you should
freak out if it's zero but don't freak
out sometimes if your credit score is
showing as poor or fair it's because of
a small problem so I know a guy one of
my students and he couldn't get a
mortgage because yet it was saying his
credit was bad and then he went on to
Credit Karma
and it was showing his credit is bad and
then he looked on Credit Karma and
looked as to why it was bad and it said
that there was an outstanding debt which
turned out to be a mobile-phone debt
from about a year ago which was
outstanding of 11-pound fifth day so he
just phoned up the company paid off the
11 pound fifth day his credit score then
increased he was able to get a mortgage
so secondly don't freak out if it's bad
find out what's wrong with it
on Credit Karma there'll be a tab
somewhere where you can find out how you
can improve your credit I'd really
recommend doing that secondly thirdly
make sure you are on the electoral roll
if you've moved house and you forgot to
register for the electril roll I don't
know why exactly but it will really
affect your credit so always make sure
that you are on the electoral rock for
is make sure that you details on credit
column I make sure that they are all up
to date your name your date of birth
your address make sure that their
current correct and up to date it helps
make sure that you have a good credit
score number five is late payments if
you had any late payments maybe you paid
for a mobile phone or a utility bill if
you paid for it late and it's now
flagging up on your credit file then
what I would recommend doing is just
ring up the company that you paid late
and ask them what you need to do to
rectify the situation just ring up the
companies and make sure that you have no
outstanding payments it's so annoying
because sometimes it can be as little as
11 pound fifth day and then that stops
you them buying a property which is
going to make you thousands of
four pounds so always make sure that
you've paid off any late payments bring
up the companies number six is use
credit sometimes people who want a good
credit they think that if they have no
credit cards they have no debts they
have no loans it's going to mean that
they have better credit somehow but it's
actually the opposite what banks and
lenders want to see when they check your
credit file is they want to see that
you're a responsible adult they want to
see that you have actually got credit
you've got credit cards you've got loans
but you just always pay back on time and
responsibly and that actually helps
improve your credit number seven don't
be stubborn what I mean by that is
sometimes companies do make mistakes I
had a situation where my I counseled my
phone bill it's always phones we do this
I counseled my phone bill and even
though I count to it they carried on
charging me and I was like this is
ridiculous and I kept trying accounts
like couldnt get hold of them so then I
just cancelled the direct debit I don't
know exactly what happened but I know
that about three years later apparently
I think that company were wrong
I owned an one month's bill a 56 pound
apparently I think they were wrong
because I've been trying to counsel for
months and months and that was now
affecting my ability to buy a house and
I was thinking oh my goodness so I
tracked it back to this phone company
and I went into the store and I said
look you know I didn't owe this money I
like I was proving to them I didn't area
but they were just I don't know I'm not
sure you know the human nature and they
wanted to fight the case and say look do
you know how hard it is to cancel with
you guys you know I tried to counsel for
months I'd finished and I knew that I
was right and I had a proof of that and
email everything to prove that but in
the end I just thought what's the point
if I fight this it could take months and
months then my house is gonna fall
through all because I was stubborn so
don't be super stubborn just think
commercially and again pay off things
that need to be paid off and don't be
stupid number eight this is a really
really important tip if like me you're a
landlord know lots of houses sometimes
what can happen and it's really
frustrating when this happens is I pay
little bounce so at one of your houses
and you might have lots of different
lenders they'll go to try and take money
out
your account and for whatever reason
because you've managed your money badly
there's no money in that account and for
the sake of one hundred and fifty pounds
for that monthly payment it then bounces
there's no money now you might have
twenty thousand a million pounds in your
other accounts but in this account you
happen to have no money and it bounced
now that can really badly affect your
credit I know I had that happen to me
once when they tried to take a payment I
didn't have money in that account so
that they didn't take the payment so
what I did was I asked the lender I said
listen
can I please give you 150 pounds one
months just to sort of sit in like your
inner is in it with you in a reserve
camp if you ever can take the payment
from me I'm good for it I do have the
money
use that one hundred and fifty pounds
and then find me and tell me and I'll
give you another hundred fifty pounds so
it just kind of just sits there in this
in this part and after doing that I did
that with all my lenders I just gave
them all I was always a month ahead so
that if they can't take it there's a
little pot and I'm sure that that's
probably saved me big-time in any in any
bouncing the light payments so really
important if you're a property investor
number nine is if there's anything
really weird showing on your credit file
on Credit Karma
and it's affecting you quit and you
don't understand it ask Credit Karma to
investigate for you don't just accept oh
I've got really bad credit if you don't
know why it's it's small you can usually
always rectify it so you know fight it
and find out if there's an error which
there can be sometimes there's errors
and it's saying you've got bad credit
just because of something that's
happened which is not your fault so
always ask things to be to be disputed
and and fight your corner and number ten
is when you are applying for loans don't
apply for lots and lots of loans all at
once because when you do that every time
you apply for credit what happens is it
leaves a print on your credit file
there's nothing wrong with having print
but if you've got lots of them
particularly if they're all close
together it makes it look like you're
desperate for money you're like Sheila
Munich I need a loan then that affects
your credit so don't be getting loads of
quotes the loans in the space of a short
time over and over if you are getting
quotes or mortgages and stuff
ask the question is this going to leave
a print on my credit
and just be mindful of that don't have
to go overboard and be crazy there's
nothing wrong with having prints we
don't want loads of prints all in one go
so those are the 10 things that will
help improve your credit there is a
bonus tip as well and that is to be
patient it does sometimes take time
you're not going to go from 500 up to
710 in the space of a few days or even a
few weeks this can take months but you
can rectify a big problem quickly which
can help you get financed so just be
patient don't write yourself off either
I've known many of my students who are
wanting to get properties they've got
even if got CC J's County Court
judgments against them they've got a
really bad credit but it doesn't
necessarily mean you can't get a
mortgage because if you're buying a
property to rent out of course they care
about your credit but more than anything
they care about the property and is the
property profitable their lending on the
property they're not lending it to you
so don't write yourself off get a good
broker be patient and I wish you all the
best in having an excellent credit and
being a successful property investor
[Music]